well you turned 50 this summer that's
amazing was it a fun party yes
yeah I turned 50 and you know it's funny
because you know I didn't throw one
party I threw like three oh because my
pet my family's gonna throw me a party
but I looked at the guest list and it
was weird because I know so many people
from the industry to like you know
friends to like you know family and you
just can't throw everybody in a party
you know I mean I look at the guest list
it was like uh Nas aunt aunt Trudy
and baby Ivory I'm like no I don't want
to hang out with Aunt Trudy and baby
Ivory so um I I separated the parties
and I realized something I I was I was
born
um on the same day as my mother and I
lost my mom uh three three years two
years ago and I got to tell you no no
birthday is ever going to be the same I
could throw 30 parties and uh the best
time I had was when I woke up and I went
to her her grave site and I just sat
there with her and played it played her
favorite music bought a cake and uh that
that was my highlight of my birthday but
I miss my girl I
cried now
really uh I'm like that looks so
beautiful oh birthday's gonna be the
same without her oh my gosh okay there's
no come on there's no sense
that is so sweet sweet okay I hope my
son does that
[Music]
foreign
[Applause]
[Music]